c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur france 24 est la
une ce soir cette attaque au niger au
moins 21 personnes dont deux policiers
ont été tués mercredi par des
djihadistes résumé contraint un bus et
un camion dans la région de tillabéri
dans le sud ouest du pays nous serons à
niamey dans ce journal et puis nous
consacrerons une grande partie de notre
édition aux conséquences alimentaires de
la guerre entre la russie et l'ukraine
sur le continent vous verrez que la
flambée des prix du gaz et du pétrole
ont aussi des conséquences nous en
parlerons avec notre invité bruno
parmentier
économiste spécialisé dans les questions
agricoles et alimentaires
au moins 20 morts dont deux policiers
c'est le bilan de cette nouvelle attaque
jihadiste est au niger une attaque
contre un bus et un camion dans la
région de tillabéri dans le sud ouest du
pays
notre correspondant à roland girard
revient sur les circonstances du drame
l'attaqué s'est déroulée en deux parties
la première sur ce bus de transport de
voyageurs et la deuxième sur un camion
de transport de marchandises les deux
occupants de ce camion ont été tuées
immolé vif de la même manière dont ont
été tués les premières victimes les
premières victimes qui se trouvaient
dans un bus de la société stm société de
transport nigérienne qui a décidé ce
matin que tous les allées et venues vers
le burkina faso était pour l'instant
interrompue cette attaque intervient
dans un contexte régional de plus en
plus tendue la zone de tillabéry et
coincé prise en étau entre deux foyers
d'insécurité le premier on vient de le
citer entre le burkina faso et le niger
au sud du niger et le deuxième entre le
mali et le niger au nord de la région de
tillabéri car du côté malien un
affrontement fait rage entre deux
groupes armés l'état islamique au grand
sahara et le mouvement pour le salut de
l'azawad ce conflit sur le territoire
malien se rapproche de plus en plus de
la zone nigérienne de la frontière
nigérienne et inflige une énorme
pression à la région de tillabéri un
ouragan de famine va s'abattre sur
certains pays du sud ce sont les mots
d'antonio goûter reste secrétaire
général de l'onu conséquence directe de
l'offensive russe en ukraine de son côté
la fao a prévenu qu'entre 8 et 13
millions de personnes supplémentaires
pourraient souffrir de la faim dans le
monde l'afrique pourrait être
particulièrement touchés
comment remplacer le blé ukrainien sur
ce marché de bukavu en république
démocratique du congo les prix ne
cessent de flamber depuis que la russie
a commencé à envahir la super puissance
agricole qui l'ukraine il faut que les
autorités fassent quelque chose sinon
nous allons mourir de faim chaque jour
il ya une nouvelle flambée des prix des
produits alimentaires la rdc est l'un
des nombreux pays africains importer
plus de 50% de son blé d'ukraine ou de
russie une situation d'extrême
dépendance alimentaire qui fait craindre
le pire à l'onu
mais devons tout faire pour éviter un
ouragan de famine
et l'effondrement du système alimentaire
mondial
au maghreb la flambée des prix avaient
commencé bien avant l'invasion de
l'ukraine une conséquence de la reprise
après la récession liés à la pandémie de
co vide et la proche du ramadan qui
provoque une frénésie d'achats ne fait
qu'amplifier le phénomène au malawi le
prix du pain s'est envolée dans cette
supérette de lilongwe les affiches se
succèdent pour informer les clients de
chaque nouvelle hausse avec pour
conséquence une chute des ventes au
rayon boulangerie
j'achète souvent du pain mais c'est de
plus en plus difficile d'en acheter
maintenant parce que les prix ont
vraiment augmenter ce qui avant
suffisait à acheter de pain ne permet
plus aujourd'hui que d'en acheter un
seul
donc on dépense beaucoup plus
est cette flambée des prix alimentaires
se conjugue avec celle des prix des
carburants qui ne fait que l'amplifier
le transport des marchandises coûte de
plus en plus cher le prix du litre de
carburant a plus que doublé en afrique
de quoi faire craindre une aggravation
de la pauvreté dans tout le continent
bruno parmentier conférencier ingénieur
économiste spécialisé dans les questions
agricoles et alimentaires est notre
invité ce soir merci d'être avec nous
tout d'abord beaucoup d'experts et je
pense que vous en faites partie disent
que cette guerre en ukraine fera sans
doute plus de morts par la famine dans
les pays du sud que par les bons dans
cet horrible conflit est-ce que c'est à
craindre malheureusement oui c'est à
dire notamment en afrique il n'y a
pratiquement aucun pays africain qui
soit autosuffisant en nourriture et
particulièrement sur les céréales il
faut se rendre compte que les pays qui
ont besoin d'acheter des céréales y en a
beaucoup mais les pays qui sont capables
d'en vendre il y en a très peu et
concrètement pour le blay c'est la
russie les états unis le canada
l'ukraine la france un peu l'allemagne
c'est quasiment tôt c'est pas les pays
qui produisent le plus c'est les
produits c'est les pays qui produisent
plus que ce qu'ils mangent parce que les
deux pays qui produisent le plus de de
céréales c'est la chine et l'inde mais
ils mangent leurs céréales en revanche
la russie et l'ukraine ne produisent
ensemble que 15% du blé mondial mais
assure 40 à 45% des exportations
donc quand vous êtes un pays africain
faisait besoin d'acheter du blé ben
c'est normal vous allez vers l'arc
rennes l'ukraine et la russie alors la
russie ça peut-être marcher le cren là
cette année c'est quasiment terminée il
se peut aussi que que cette crise
alimentaire provoque des émeutes de la
faim et même des révoltes et peut-être
même des guerres en 2007
le prix des céréales a triplé il ya eu
des émeutes de la faim de 36 pays et des
normes déstabilisation
géopolitique trois ans après en 2010 de
nouveau le prix des céréales augmente et
ça a été une cause directe estime des
printemps arabes
le prix des céréales est déjà nettement
plus élevé qu'en 2007 et en 2010 ça n'a
pas fini ça va augmenter et ça va durer
les gens quand ils ont vraiment faim
verser la différence d'autres manger un
peu et ne plus de manger du tout dans
beaucoup de pays où il ya déjà beaucoup
d'injustices peu de solidarité et déjà
des difficultés à se nourrir
les gens vont vraiment avoir faim
j'imagine qu'ils vont protester alors
vous l'avez dit un bruno parmentier la
crise du blé mais il ya d'autres crises
directement liée à la guerre en ukraine
par exemple la russie et son allié
biélorusses sont également deux grands
exportateurs d'engrais chimiques de
nombreux pays en dépendent pour leur
propre agriculture c'est le cas de
l'afrique du sud voyez ce reportage de
caroline dumay et de stephan genz dans
la province du cap la haute saison pour
les pommes et pour les pouvoirs se
termine habituellement plus de 20% des
poires sud africaines sont exportés vers
la russie
mais ces derniers fruits de saison
seront cette année écoulée à bas prix
sur le marché local personne pourtant ne
sait que faire de la majorité de la
production qui se trouvait déjà en mer
quand la guerre a commencé
on estime qu'entre les pommes les poires
et les prunes plus de 800000 cartons
sont coincés en mer ou dans les ports
européens
faute d'avoir pu atteindre la russie
pour tous les fruits les gens se
précipitent pour trouver d'autres
marchés mais ils vont se retrouver en
europe avec un énorme surplus
en croire les experts les fruits risque
même d'être pourri avant de pouvoir être
consommée dans son bureau du cap le
ministre provincial de l'agriculture
cherche partout d'autres débouchés
southan morris export
certains de ces exportateurs ont déjà
décidé de dérouter les bateaux sur
rotterdam une partie de la cargaison
pourra être débarqués et même être
offerte à titre d' aide humanitaire en
pologne ou en ukraine
la guerre aura aussi un impact sur les
céréales à 40% du blé consommer en
afrique du sud vient d'ukraine les
fermiers sud africains peuvent essayer
de planter plus de blé cet hiver pour
compenser le déficit mais il explique
que les récoltes reviendront chez tout
le monde dit que le prix du blé va
exploser les coûts de production aussi
augmentent
au profit des fermiers
les coûts de production pourrait doubler
en raison notament en des engrais dont
90 % provenaient de russie toutes les
plantes seront donc affectés y compris
celles qui servent à alimenter le bétail
sur cette ferme depuis le début de la
guerre on a déjà eu un surcoût de 50
centimes par litre de lait
les agriculteurs sud-africain gère donc
la situation au jour le jour mais ils
sont convaincus que la guerre entre la
russie et l'ukraine aura un impact sur
leurs revenus comme sur ceux du
consommateur et la crise en ukraine
n'est pas la seule à avoir des
conséquences le réchauffement climatique
et les conflits ont déjà
considérablement affecté l'agriculture
dans certains pays c'est le cas au
burkina faso pays agricoles touchées de
plein fouet par l'insécurité les
agriculteurs abandonnent leurs terres
pour fuir les djihadistes et de nombreux
déplacés sont menacées par la faim notre
correspondant à ouagadougou kalidou sy a
rencontré et grégoire brousse directeur
pays action contre la faim au burkina
faso écouter
bonjour bonjour est ce qu'on peut dire
que la crise sécuritaire que connaît
aujourd'hui burkina faso est la cause de
la crise humanitaire tout à fait
aujourd'hui on a une crise humanitaire
d'ampleur au burkina et ce depuis
plusieurs années
aujourd'hui on a près de 3,5 millions de
personnes qui sont dans un des besoins
essentiels des d'humanitaires et les
personnes déplacées donc subissent en
fait la pression des groupes armés non
étatiques
ils sont obligés de fuir leur village on
les assiste mais aussi on doit aller
assister plus loin les gens qui n'ont
pas réussi à se déplacer dans quelle
mesure la guerre en ukraine qui a
commencé il ya un peu plus de trois
semaines à tellure aura un impact sur
l'insécurité alimentaire et de se faire
sur la flambée des prix des denrées
alimentaires au burkina faso il est
clair qu'il va y avoir un impact je
rappelle juste que avant même le
déclenchement de cette guerre la
situation alimentaire nutritionnelle au
burkina faso est très très préoccupante
notamment du fait de l'insécurité
certains paysans ne pouvant plus à les
cultiver leurs champs du fait aussi des
mesures sur le colis de 19 avec des
fermetures de marché de frontières et
maintenant avec cette guerre
on est très préoccupé parce que
l'ukraine est le quatrième exportateur
de denrées alimentaires 30% de
l'importation du blé au burkina c'est la
russie et on note déjà des flambées des
prix donc c'est par exemple 50% sur le
1000 37% sur le sorgho ça va avoir aussi
un impact cette guerre sur le prix des
hydrocarbures et donc là les chaînes
logistiques
le programme alimentaire mondial voit
d'ores et déjà des délais dans ses
approvisionnements et donc le coût pour
les opérations humanitaires va augmenter
à titre d'exemple il y a deux ans le pam
a acheté 290 dollars la tonne de blé
aujourd'hui c'est presque 400 euros la
tonne
certains donateurs noël j'ai ont indiqué
qu'ils devaient réduire leurs
financements pour soutenir les
opérations en ukraine qu'en est-il
d'action contre la faim et vous inquiète
tout à fait on est on est inquiet
pourquoi parce que déjà l'année dernière
le plan de réponse humanitaire qui
étaient environ 600 millions de dollars
a été financé qu'à à peine 40 45 %
aujourd'hui on voit que les besoins sont
en train d'exploser au burkina faso avec
encore plus de populations déplacées qui
sont dans le besoin et on redoute
effectivement que la communauté
internationale les bailleurs de fonds
prennent une décision de réorienter des
fonds vers cette crise humanitaire qui
existent en ukraine et nous nous
appelons la communauté internationale à
ne pas oublier la crise au sahel et
particulièrement au burkina faso qui vit
aussi une crise aiguë humanitaire avec
des besoins importants à couvrir voilà
pour les autres inquiétudes bruno
parmentier on a souvent parlé du soft
power que certains états développent
qu'en est il du foot power est ce que
cela peut devenir une arme redoutable
évidemment je veux dire la réalité c'est
tout le monde a besoin de manger tous
les jours quand on ne produit pas dans
le pays et quand on veut pas
approvisionner ça dure ça dure des mois
et donc au bout d'un moment bah
effectivement c'est un pouvoir de vie et
de mort
qu'un petit nombre de pays ont sur la
grande majorité des pays du monde et en
particulier la quasi totalité des pays
africains je ne connais aucun pays
africain qui soit vraiment autosuffisant
en nourriture donc c'est une menace
directissime sans compter le fait qu'on
a entendu 7,7 ce responsable humanitaire
mais les pays donateurs ils vont
forcément
donné beaucoup d aide à l'europe les
réfugiés etc mais pendant ce temps là on
va avoir le plus grand mal dans les ong
à trouver des financements pour des pays
qui sont entre guillemets - moins à la
mode dans les pays occidentaux donc même
ça l'aide alimentaire ils vont plus
avoir d'argent pour le faire et même
s'ils ont de l'argent ils ont plus de
blé à acheter donc c'est vrai que c'est
extrêmement préoccupant et sur le fond
jeudi il faut absolument à moyen terme
augmenter fortement très fortement la
production agricole en afrique du nord
au sud et en attendant il faut
effectivement que arrivé à partager le
buzz via merci beaucoup en tout cas
merci bruno parmentier gel rappelle que
vous êtes expert en questions agricoles
alimentaires et merci pour votre pour
votre expertise et la fin de journal de
l'afrique reste avec nous l'info
continue sur france 24
[Musique]